hello
today we are
going to talk about
how swings work
and how you can get them to keep on
swinging
when you're an old man
but first
we'll
do experiments
in the lab
this contraption made by paul mundy this
thing is a series of weights there are
nine of them so that one is the center
of these and we'll call that the center
of mass and from there as i hang it down
i've got a pendulum
which goes up and is supported just
about here on the bar so this distance
between the fifth weight there i'll call
the length of the pendulum because
that's the distance that's travelling
now then if i leave this at rest
i can't do anything to this the only
freedom i have is i can move the string
at the top and shorten the pendulum
because as you can see i've just raised
it up and then i can lower it down i'm
going to raise it up
and lower it down now the pendulum
actually swings so what i'm going to do
is set it in motion
and then repeat this idea of lifting it
up and down i'm going to lift it up when
it gets to the middle there
of the swing
so having got that as my point of
reference i'm going to pull it up pull
it up pull it up pull it up pull it up
pull it up there
there
there
there
there
there
there
there
there
there oh dear it's getting a bit too
violent for me anyway you can see i fed
more and more energy just by changing
the length of the pendulum
and the idea of pushing on the string
and changing the amplitude of the swing
is called parametric resonance because
i'm amplifying this motion by changing
the length of the pendulum which is one
of the two parameters that comes into it
the other is the acceleration downwards
due to gravity the reason
i can feed energy in is that when this
thing swings around the bottom
very fast there is in a tension in the
string called the centrifugal force
it's as so you've got a hammer and
you're swirling around and then going to
throw it don't tell me it doesn't pull
on your arms because it really does when
you do that and it's that tension in the
string coming because this is
swinging around which is increase when
it's going fast at the bottom and it's
that allowing you to do work on it at
the right point of the cycle
you don't pull on it when it's at
extremity because then it's stationary
and there's no centrifugal force and if
you pull when it's at that extremity or
that extremity it won't work
but anywhere in between it will and the
optimum is when it's at
the bottom
so the main idea if you want to get a
swing to go
a bit further is to feed energy in
somehow and in this case all i'm doing
is changing the effective length that is
from the point at the top where it's
pivoting
and the center of mass of the object
down below well i'm on the swing
and
my center of mass i reckon is somewhere
just below my belly button
and then the pivot point about which the
pendulum swings is up there so the
question is
how do i
have some injection of energy because
there's no finger at the top changing
the length of the pendulum nothing at
all up there so i've somehow got to
change the length of the pendulum myself
well first of all i can push myself off
just by starting at an angle
and then i'm going to rock backwards and
forwards
so when i go forward i lean back and
when i go back
i can lean the other way and when i go
forward i lean back and when i go back i
lean the other way and if you do that
after a while you can go much higher
oh dear
i'm too old for this so when i was going
forward
as i remember it
i pulled on the ropes and leaned
backwards and as a result as you can see
my belly button has gone maybe a bit
down but i've pulled this up
so that it makes an angle and if i can
show you from the side it now looks more
like that
there's my belly button down there
but the line to this to there has been
shortened because i've made this into a
triangle
and so the actual distance between my
belly button and the pivot has got
smaller
and when i go back the other way
i push on this
i push on this and as i push on this
it gets bent the other way and my belly
button is still here
but this distance is a bit smaller so in
effect all i've done is the same thing
as the finger pushing up and down on the
string by making the pendulum length
from my center of mass to the pivot
point
change twice every cycle at the right
point if i chose the wrong point it
wouldn't work nearly so well and every
kid knows how to do this you sit down
there you go forward
and then you put your feet forwards
and back and forwards and back
and you don't realize that in order to
do that you must pull on the chain
i would drop my legs
drop my weight
drop my weight
drop my weight twice every cycle
and hope that that would amplify it